Welcome students to
the Pharmacology of the
Antifungal Agents. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact me if
you'd like to chat about
pharmacology. Bring your
friends if you wish.
The learning objectives are
listed here. I put titles
on them to help you
organize them in your mind.
And preparation materials.
I encourage you to learn
the information any
way you like and strongly
encourage you to do
the practice questions
so you know what you
know and you know what
you'd like to find out.
And links if you
wish to use them.
And key points. I've put
I've listed them really
in bullets. It's just
the information you need
without explanations. You
can use it as a review
if you wish or an
introduction to this lecture.
And it's just three slides.
This is an overview
of how the fungi are
classified as yeasts,
molds, and dimorphic.
We will be talking about
fungi in relation to their
spectrums of action, I
mean antifungal agents in
respect to their spectrums
of action, so it may
help you to be able to
visualize this chart. Yeasts,
candida,
and cryptococcus I'll
be talking about, molds
aspergillus particularly
dermatophytes mucormycosis I
will mention and the
dimorphics the clinical
response to antifungal
treatment can be protracted
lengthy because fungi
are complex slow-growing
organisms with thick walls
and they are often embedded
deep in tissues I've
listed the opportunistic
fungal pathogens here. You
can see the Candida and
Aspergillus, Cryptococcus
that I mentioned before,
Pneumocystis urobichii,
as mentioned in other
lectures, and the
Mucorales, notice the
Rhizopus, Mucor,
Rhizomucor, other species.
These are common
and they can be very
serious progressive
of infections. The
endemic fungal pathogens
are listed here.
I draw your attention
to the bottom.
This is why we
care. The incidence
of fungal infections is rising.
Morbidity in immunocompromised
patients is high.
Let's take a look now at
how fungal cells, which
are eukart karyotic cells,
differ from human cells.
They have ergosterol as
their primary fungal cell
membrane sterol, whereas we
have cholesterol. So it's
a different sterol. They
have six thick cell walls.
I've listed the drug
targets on the left-hand
side, but let's Let's take
a look at this figure,
ergosterol here,
and it's indicated
in the figure in
these little tiny
blobs, these bubbles.
Ergosterol is formed
from linosterol, there's
an enzyme here to
catalyze the conversion,
and azoles block this step.
Squalene is an
early precursor, and
Turbinephine
blocks this enzyme.
Amphotericin B and
Nystatin, these
are polyenes, they're called,
form pores in the membrane.
and these are holes these
are what these are aqueous
channels and various
electrolytes will flow out
and that will lead to the
death of the fungal cell
here is the strong cell wall
it's made of proteins beta
glucans chitin beta Beta
-glucan synthase is indicated
in the figure here,
forming these little hexagons
that are going to link
together, and this is a
different type of beta-glucan.
See how it's nicely
cross-linked? The
echinocandins block beta
-glucan synthase, and
that's going to weaken
the cell wall. Water
can rush in, leading
to osmotic rupture.
Resistance. We always
have to think about that
with our antimicrobials
and our anti-cancer drugs,
but that's not the topic
of discussion today.
Resistance usually develops
slowly because fungal
cells grow slowly, and
fungal cells do not transfer
genes between themselves,
unlike the bacteria.
The clinically important
mechanisms, in other words,
the ones that we see most
frequently, are related
to alteration of the
target protein. That makes
sense. That happens with
all drug therapy that
targets something that is
going to be altered, like
in cancer cells, as in
bacterial cells, and so on.
And expression of efflux pumps.
We see that very frequently.
The resistance mechanisms
have been most studied in
Candida albicans, but less
so in the other fungi.
Let's begin with
Amphoteris and be a very,
very important drug to
be able to understand.
It is an amphipathic,
amphoteric, polyene
macrolide that
comes from a natural
source, the bacterium
streptomyces nodosus.
This describes basically
its structure and structure
activity relationship
explains if you understand
structure activity relationship
you're going to be able
to understand the pharmacology
of amphotericin B.
It is a broad spectrum
fungicidal antifungal agent.
So it has this
polyene region, which
is hydrophobic.
That means it has
double carbon-to
-carbon double bonds.
It has a hydrophilic region.
Hemp, it's amphipathic.
It has acid and base
capabilities, which it
means is polar. It's
got polarity, I should
say. So it's got non-polar
regions, polar regions,
hydrophilic regions,
hydrophobic regions.
So imagine that it is,
because of this structure,
it can get into the
lipid bilayer and form
this pore with the
hydrophobic portion binding
to, or lipophilic
portion binding to the
lipophilic parts of the
membrane, and the hydrophilic
portion forming this
water channel, a pore.
The polar parts
are involved also
with stabilizing that channel.
pharmacokinetics I put
the takeaways up here
hopefully as you proceed
through your through
your years of medical
education you'll come
to the point where you
can just automatically
provide informed
information in this one
sentence on
pharmacokinetics of whatever
drugs you happen to
use in your practice.
IV only, highly
protein bound, high
concentration in
tissues, poor ***********
into the CNS, think meningitis,
slow elimination, think
long half-life, cleared
primarily by kidneys, think
dosing adjustment in renal
insufficiency, and I
mentioned before a long half
-life, a long terminal half
-life. The lipid and liposomal
formulations decrease
accumulation in kidney
tissue and are associated
with lower nephrotoxicity,
which allows higher dosing,
improved tolerability.
They come in different
formulations. Looking at the
left, the conventional
deoxycholate formulation is
the traditional one, the
first one to be developed.
The amphotericin B is
combined with deoxycholate
because the
amphotericin B is really
hydrophobic. It will
not go into IV solution.
So, by combining it with other
things, it will get
it into solution.
Now, this is a non
-lipid formulation.
I'll talk more about that.
This is the only one
that can be given
intrathecally. Remember,
poor ***********
into the CNS, but
it's toxic there.
And then I've just listed the
various features of it below.
Now, let's take a look
on the right hand side,
the liposomal and lipid
complex formulations.
This helps keep it into
solution, get it where it
needs to go, kind of protects
the amphotericin B within
these lipid complex
within the liposome. There
are different formulations
and that will allow higher
concentrations in the liver,
spleen, and lungs than
we see with conventional
amphotericin B, and higher
concentration correlates
with an enhanced effect.
Now they do have poor
CNS *********** also.
And the rest is the same,
I've also highlighted here
the non-linear kinetics
with the liposomal forms.
half-life varies.
This slide and the next
slide are just really
illustrations and explanations
of the different formulations.
I want you to take away
how they are different,
which is conventional,
is non-lipid, and the
others are liposomal or
lipid. That's the two things.
And why that matters.
It matters in relation
to infusion-related
toxicity, nephrotoxicity.
But I've put them
here so you can kind
of conceptualize
within your mind how
these different
formulations are prepared.
I'm not going to test
you specifically on it,
but I thought you might
like to understand.
So let's talk about the
mechanism of action now.
Amphotericin B associates with
the ergosterol in
the fungal cell.
In this illustration,
the artist
has made Amphotericin
B like this.
It will associate
into the fungal cell.
We see the artist put
it here like this.
and form pores. And out of
these pores, the ions flow.
They leak out.
In addition, the
ergosterol is sequestered
further, which compromises
the membrane integrity.
In any case, between
these two things,
the fungal cell dies,
fungicidal action.
Now, why is amphotericin
B selective for
fungal cells? Well,
let us say it's more
selective for the
ergosterol in fungal cells.
It can bind to human
membrane sterols, the
cholesterol, but with
much lower affinity.
and the liposomal
tend to bind even with
lower affinity to the
human cholesterol because
they're wrapped up
in that lipid stuff.
Acquired resistance
really is very rare.
There are fungi that are
inherently intrinsically
resistant. The acquired
resistance though
thankfully is rare,
and that's going to be
related to various ERG
genes which form the
membrane sterol, argosterol.
Therapeutic uses, well,
it's serious infections,
potentially life
-threatening progressive
infections. Why?
Because Amphotericin
B is complicated
to use and toxic.
So aspergillosis, mucormycosis,
cryptococcal meningitis,
deep invasive candidiasis.
These are just terrible
infections and the
immunocompromised patient
is at even greater risk.
This is just a picture
comparing the hyphae
of aspergillus and
mucor. These are molds.
And we see CT images,
invasive aspergillosis
on the left-hand side,
including, this is
in lungs, and on
the right-hand side
in brain tissue.
so what how do we treat
with this I've put in the
upper right hand side what
you need to know from this
slide you need to be able
to understand it to be
able to talk about it
treatment of cryptococcal
meningitis this is not only
important for treatment of
cryptococcal meningitis
which is very important,
but also for understanding
this treatment approach.
Amvotericin B is
first line and it's
used in combination
with flucytosine,
which we'll talk about
as the next drug.
Patients who are
immunocompromised
are particularly susceptible.
AIDS patients
patients tend to get this,
but patients who do not
have age who are
immunocompromised can also get it.
So induction, that means
when we're first starting the
therapy, we want to induce
that fungal cell killing.
the lipid liposomal
versions are now preferred
given iv once a day plus
flucytosine which we'll talk
about more on the next
one flucytosine is oral
it's given every six hours
for two to four weeks
until the patient no
longer has fever and the cf
culture csf cultures are
negative that's how you
monitor. That's how you
know what the response is.
Consolidation, that's the
next phase. All right, we've
initiated, we've brought
down that, we've initiated
that fungal cell killing. Now
we want to consolidate the
effects. So we're switching
over now to fluconazole.
these two drugs can be
quite toxic and fluconazole
will be effective so why don't
we start with fluconazole
because for induction
therapy fluconazole is
not as effective as the other
two together so fluconazole
which has good cn really
good cns ***********
is given once daily for
eight weeks. It's quite
tolerable. This is a
non-AIDS patient. AIDS
patients are going to need
it for a longer period
of time. And then the
maintenance phase. This
is the suppressive phase.
We've gotten to the
point where the CSF levels
cultures are negative
and we want to keep it there.
Fluconazole, once a day,
you see it's a lower
dose now, to prevent
relapse, this is 6 to 12
months in the non-AIDS
patient. For a person
who has AIDS, they have
to take it continuously
until their CD4
cell count rises
and their viral load decreases.
Now, getting back
to amphotericin B to
achieve fungal cell
killing in the brain.
We mentioned before that
amphotericin B has very
poor *********** into
the CNS. But that said,
this particular regimen has
shown in good trials and
long experience to be
effective when given IV.
So, clearly enough of
the drug gets there
to be effective when given
along with flucytosine,
which has excellent
CNS ***********.
This is an image here of
cryptococcal meningitis
on the right hand
side and it came with
this image of toxoplasmosis
which is a protozoam
that AIDS patients are
often infected with.
cryptococcus with the
India ink preparation.
You can see all these
little cells and on the
right one is a high-powered
photomicrograph of the
meninges showing the
cryptococcus neoformans.
Those are the arrows.
Okay.
I mentioned toxicity
quite a few times now.
And the major toxicity
with amphotericin B
is the nephrotoxicity.
So what does it cause?
It causes azotemia, which means
increase in the blood, urea,
nitrogen.
and what is that
the bun because
those waste products
are not clearing
acute kidney injury and
that's going to decrease
renal perfusion decrease
glomerular filtration
right renal tubular
acidosis and that's going
to cause wasting or
excretion of these ions
And that's these
electrolytes. And that's
going to disturb
plasma electrolytes.
And what do we do? We have to
give some normal
saline hydration.
Blood anemia. Well,
why anemia? And this
is related, again,
to the nephrotoxicity
because of the decrease
in erythropoietin
production. So that
will lead to the anemia.
And infusion related
effects. These
can be quite something.
It's called shake
and bake, fever
and chills, rigor,
along with vomiting and
headache and general yucky
feeling, and low blood
pressure, rapid breathing,
and it can cause
thrombophlebitis. So of course we
give pre-medications, which
should help to some extent.
shake and bake.
Intrasecal, remember this
is only the deoxycholate,
arachnoiditis,
delirium, and seizures.
I'm not going to go over
these questions in the
interest of time. They're
here for you. I encourage
you to stop the video
and think about these.
What are the advantages
of liposomal amphotericin
B and lipid complex
compared to the deoxycholi?
What is the mechanism of
amphotericin B's
antifungal action?
And what are the
toxicities associated with
amphotericin B
administrations? See if you
can remember off the
top of your head.
Otherwise, go back and
look and remind yourself.
Physical properties of
amphotericin B molecule
that are probably
important for its fungal
killing activity,
what accounts for its
relatively selective
toxicity against fungi,
what are the mechanisms
of resistance, and
amphotericin B is an
important therapeutic for
patients, for what patients,
and what infection.
That brings us now to
flucytosine, 5-FC. It
is a fluorinated
pyrimidine analog converted
to the active 5-FU, 5
-fluorouracil, within fungal
cells. That's an
important consideration.
It is converted within fungal
cells, not within human cells.
It's this right here
on the picture. There
was some pharmacokinetic,
or I should
say some overview
of the pharmacology.
This is actually
whole pharmacology.
Pharma, I hope you
pronounce the whole word,
cology.
Oral, mentioned that before,
pro-drug, rapid, good
absorption, bioavailability,
90%. That's really good.
Good CSF ***********.
We care about all of that in
terms of optimizing
our therapy.
Intracellular deamination
in yeast, so it's
turned into its active 5
-FU within the yeast cell,
and also in gut bacteria,
which I'll get to.
Urine excretion of the 5-FC.
Oh, is urine excretion?
Renal adjustments are
necessary. It's got a
pretty short half-life, but
look at the difference
in people who have renal
failure between from 3
to 6 hours to 200 hours.
And it has to be given
every 6 hours, which means
a kind of a sleeping
dose. You have to wake up.
Mechanism of action, like
5-fluorouracillid inhibits
RNA and DNA synthesis.
It's on the next slide.
Resistance emerges rapidly
when this drug is used
alone, and I'll mention
why on the next slide.
So thinking now about
our renal dosing,
remember, Amphotericin B
is nephrotoxic. We give
flucitazine with
Amphotericin B, so there can
be a change in that
patient's renal function
during therapy, So that
has to be monitored.
And the toxicities
are dose-related.
The drug is fungistatic,
has a narrow spectrum.
So we know about
cryptococcus neophormans
and some candidas
and the fungi that
cause chromoblastomycosis,
some dermatitis.
Really, that's it. Remember,
fungistatic, narrow
spectrum, and the specific
fungi that it does treat.
I mentioned the uses
here, and now let's talk
about the adverse
effects, the toxicities.
Well, it tends
to be really well
tolerated in people
who have renal function
because it's being cleared out.
So what are the adverse
effects? Well, first
we have to think about
what is the active form.
It's 5-FU. It's 5-FU that's
causing these toxicities.
Well, why is it causing
toxicities if human
cells do not convert
it, do not convert
flucytosine to fluorouracil?
Well, the reason is
bacteria in the gut
microbiome. Some of them
do convert it, and that
5-FU gets absorbed.
So that's where the
dose dependence comes
in. The more 5-FU that
gets absorbed, the
greater the risk, the
greater severity of the
adverse effects. So
bone marrow suppression.
Bone marrow or
myelosuppression, same thing.
Liver, GI.
What happens in the GI?
I will think about it
as a cancer drug, nausea,
vomiting, diarrhea,
mucositis,
stomatitis, those things.
Adverse events have
been seen in animal
reproduction studies,
so we're not going to
use flucytosine unless
we're saving somebody's
life. Wait until
they're not pregnant.
Flucytosine mechanism of
action. All right, first it
has to get into the fungal
cell, and it is cytosine
permease, please remember
this, this transporter,
that takes up 5-FC into
the fungal cell, and then
it needs to be activated.
it. So cytosine deaminase.
Let's look at this one
here. It's easier. Here's
the amino group and
it's been removed here.
Cytosine deaminase. So we
have cytosine permease,
cytosine deaminase, which
is on here someplace.
And then we get 5-fluorouracil
to 5-fluorouracil
monophosphate.
And that is with this uridine
5-phosphoribosyl transferase.
And RNA synthesis and DNA
synthesis gets impaired.
We've already learned
about 5-FU, and this
is now looking at it
in a different context.
So I mentioned that it's
only fungal cells or
some bacterial species.
Why not human cells?
Because humans do not
have cytosine permease,
and they do not have
this cytosine deaminase.
And also, very low
amounts of this
uridine phosphoribosyl
transferase.
So I put all of
that down here. Your
knowledge, what is the
basis of flucytosine
selectivity, of its toxicity,
of its intracellular
cytotoxicity, of its
therapeutic uses, and
adverse effects, and
how can they be reduced?
Monitoring renal function.
Now the azoles. This
is a big, important,
important, important
group of antifungals.
These block the
conversion of lanosterol
to ergosterol, and
therefore we don't get
ergosterol secreted
into the cell membrane.
Broad-spectrum
activity, fungistatic.
I put the stars on all
of these because they're
all really important
for you to understand.
You see them in clinical
practice. You see
them on board exams. And
there are a whole list
of topical products. I
put STARS only on two.
Clotrimazole. I mean, I
should say ketoconazole
because you can learn
about it twice. It's the
two for one. And clotrimazole
because I want to
mention a route of
administration. Takeaways.
This is the takeaways
from this chart.
I'll bet you can see
a pattern already.
Oral, oral, oral,
oral, oral, oral,
all oral. We have some IV.
Okay, why would we
be giving them IV?
Must be for serious infections.
CYP, CYP, CYP, CYP, P
glycoprotein, P glycoprotein.
What are we thinking there?
Oof, drug interactions.
High potential for
drug interactions.
So takeaways.
Low plasma protein binding.
Diffusion across the
blood-brain barrier.
That's variable
between the drugs.
Bioavailability
and half-life vary.
Extensive hepatic
metabolism for most of them.
Inhibition of CYP3A4.
Every single one of
them to some extent.
Some strongly. This
one not very strongly.
And other CYPs are inhibited as
well. Look at the half-lives.
Okay.
Voraconazole, 6 hours.
Isovuconazole, 130
hours. And so on.
Ytriconazole 24 to 42, oh,
that looks good for once a day.
Fluconazole 22 to 31, that
looks good for once a day.
Ditto for prosaconazole.
Ketoconazole we really
don't use ****** anymore
in this country, but we
need to talk about it.
So make sure you
look at the patterns.
Make sure you know
which ones cross the
CNS, which is basically
just these two.
and which ones don't.
That's going to
be important when
we're thinking about therapy.
Okay,
mechanism.
Well, these inhibit 14
-alpha-demethylase. That
is the enzyme that I
mentioned that converts
linosterol to ergosterol,
and it is a CYP.
with, and here's the HEN
group with the iron in there.
And it's known as CYP51,
in case you want to know
that. And it is expressed
by the ERG11 gene
that will come up when
we talk about resistance.
I
just put this scheme here,
this biochemical pathway.
So they block the
conversion, and that
will decrease the
agosterol concentration
in the fungal cell
membrane naturally.
So that's going to inhibit
fungal membrane function.
And at the same time,
the linosterol is going
to accumulate behind
that blocked enzyme.
These are intermediates,
and that will disrupt the
integrity and function of
the cell membrane. So you
have these two things
going on at the same time.
Decreased ergosterol and
increased linosterol
intermediate.
And they're both
involved with leading to
the fungal cell from
stopping proliferation.
Gross arrest.
Remember, they're fungistatic.
We need an immune system
to help with that.
Resistance. Well, makes
sense. Our target.
So alterations in the ERG11
gene, which will have a
lower affinity for the
azole, but will be able to
continue to form ergosterol.
And then efflux pumps. And
another one here. It's not
a biggie, but it can occur.
Increased production
of the linosterol
that will out
-compete the azole.
Spectrum of azole antifungals.
I put it in this little chart
to help you visualize it.
The takeaway with this
slide is the spectrum
of action directly
influences the
usefulness in the treatment
of specific infections.
We saw that with
the antibacterials,
the
antivirals, and so on.
Remember to think about the
risks of resistance and
adverse effects when making
treatment decisions for
the individual patient.
the checks indicate
spectrums of action so
they're all effective
against candidiasis and c
neoformins but fluconazole
remember cns ***********
cns well fluconazole
will ********* the CNS
very well and get to the
meningeal cneiformins.
What?
Intraconazole.
Remember, low CNS
***********, but it's good for
basically everything except
mucormycosis. Speaking
of mucormycosis, only
these two, posaconazole
and isovuconazole, which
have been developed after
the other three, are
useful against mucomycosis.
Onychomycosis, so
basically the only
one on this list
is istraconazole.
Tinea,
basically it's istraconazole.
It's gluconazole,
okay, but not really
used for that.
So you see how to
read this chart?
I want to bring your
attention back to
aspergillosis, this
terrible mold infection.
We have several here that
are useful for aspergillosis.
So can we use
something other than
amphotericin B, which
we know is so toxic,
and azoles are much less
toxic than amphotericin B?
Well, yes.
But first we have
to know does it get
into the CNS for the
CNS infections? Yes,
voraconazole. Does
that make sense to you?
Takeaways from this
slide and I will repeat.
Spectrums of action
indicate uses,
the drugs of
choice, and whether
or not there's CNS ***********.
Posaconazole and
isovuconazole are the only
azoles with in vitro
activity against mucoralis.
And prophylaxis
of invasive fungal
infections are all of these.
These are preventing
the fungal infections
from taking hold in
immunocompromised patients
with hematologic
malignancy, stem cell
transplant, and solid
organ transplant patients.
So I put drugs of choice
on the various slides.
So itraconazole, what
are the drugs of choice?
Well, all of these dimorphics.
Fluconazole, initial
choice for consolidation
and maintenance of
cryptococcal meningitis.
And candidemia,
candidiasis, we see
that here. And they
can be used in
coccidiomycosis also.
You've learned
about these fungi.
You should be remembering
the fungi you've
learned about and
now correlating it
with the fungal
infections they cause and
the drugs that can be
used to treat them.
Voriconazole, drug of choice
for invasive infections.
Voriconazole, does that
sound like something
that it's good to know?
Good CNS ***********.
We have our aspergillosis.
Candidemia, including
fluoconazole-resistant
strains, which are,
there are quite a few.
Disseminated
candida infections.
Cryptococcal meningitis
for consolidation and
maintenance as an
alternative to fluconazole.
Serious infections
by dimorphic fungi.
What a drug.
Posoconazole and
isoviconazole have the
broadest spectrums of
the azoles and that's
because they pick up
these mucorales fungi.
So do you see how to
look at this chart
and know what's
important from it?
Class adverse effects.
And I put some drug
specific on the next slide.
So they're certainly not
as toxic as amphotericin
B. but they do have
their own constellation
of potentially serious
toxicities. So hepatotoxicity,
that can just be
increase in the AST and
ALT in the blood or it
can progress all the way
to liver failure, but
fortunately that's rare.
QT interval prolongation,
trocede de plant,
ventricular arrhythmias.
So many drugs fall in
that category. And these
azole antifungals are
often given to people who
are on chronic medications
that also cause QT
interval prolongation.
Plus, the azole antifungals
are CYP3A4 strong inhibitors.
Neurologic peripheral
neuropathy. This is with
long-term use generally,
and peripheral
neuropathy is very
concerning to the patients.
Most common with itraconazole,
but it can occur with others.
Hypersensitivity
reactions, we expect
that with all drugs
to some degree.
and pregnancy avoid
unless the benefit to
the mother outweighs
the risk to the fetus
i mentioned drug
interactions a bunch of times
now here's an
interesting one that you
may not be thinking
about automatically
ketoconazole itraconazole
and posaconazole
taken ****** need
to have an acid
environment in order
to be fully absorbed.
So a carbonated
beverage like ginger
ale or Coca-Cola or something,
or RC-Cola or some other cola.
And taking it with food.
Now, people who are not
taking antacids, not
taking proton pump
inhibitors, not taking H2
blockers, shouldn't be a
problem. But for those people
whose pH in their
stomach has been blocked,
I should say reduction of
pH in their stomach has been
blocked by these drugs then
they're going to need to
be thinking about taking
it with an acidic beverage.
All right drug specific.
Itraconazole has been
associated with congestive heart
failure so it's contraindicated
in those patients.
Voriconazole, remember
this drug that
just does everything
except the mucorales.
Ophthalmic effects, vision
color changes, scleritis,
optic neuritis,
and blurred vision
might be the first sign of it.
Peripheral neuropathy can be
rapid, debilitating,
irreversible.
Encephalopathy, this is high
concentrations of the IV.
and a periosteal disease.
Metabolism related.
Ketoconazole.
This is one reason why we don't
use it anymore. One of several.
It is a strong inhibitor
of steroidogenesis. So
it's not only the
inhibition of the fungal
enzyme, 14-alpha demethylase,
but also this one,
17-alpha-hydroxylase,
and also 11
-beta-hydroxylase
at higher amounts.
And in fact,
ketoconazole has
actually been used
systemically specifically
for this purpose.
pseudohyperaldosteronism
with hypertension and
hypokalemia well
hyperaldosteronism means increased
aldosterone and so aldosterone
binds to mineralocorticoid
receptors and that causes
sodium and water to be
reabsorbed which is going
to elevate blood pressure
And at the same time, it causes
potassium to be excreted.
Well, this is pseudo
-hyperaldosteronism. It means
aldosterone is not involved.
So what's happening?
This occurs with
idraconazole and
postaconazole most frequently.
By blocking 11-beta
-hydroxysteroid dehydrogenase
type 2, this enzyme
inactivates cortisol that's its
job now cortisol is able to
activate mineralocorticoid
receptors just like
aldosterone is but wherever
those receptors are located
so is 11-beta-hydroxy
steroid dehydrogenase type
2 so that it will inactivate
cortisol and allow
aldosterone to do the work.
And aldosterone is secreted
only when it's needed.
Now, if we inactivate
that, if we inhibit
that enzyme, then
cortisol is not going
to be inactivated and
cortisol is going to
activate the
mineralocorticoid receptors.
And that will do
increase sodium in water,
increasing the blood pressure,
and increase potassium
excretion, that will
lower potassium levels.
An effect just like
aldosterone. So,
pseudo-hyperaldosteronism with
hypertension and hypokalemia.
Pretty straightforward.
When prescribing oral,
azole, antifungal therapy,
certain precautions should be
considered and recommendations
should be made to the
patient. So I've listed
them here. What do we have
to think about? What drugs
are they taking? What are
their comorbid conditions?
Are they at risk
for ventricular
arrhythmia with
increased QT interval?
Does it need to be taken
with food? Does it need to
be taken on an empty stomach?
What patient education
do we need to provide and
what monitoring do we need
to do? This is basically
true of all drug therapy.
So here are the check
your knowledge questions.
Which drug is first line
for the treatment of fungal
infections by dimorphic
fungi? Which drug is for
consolidation and maintenance
of cryptococcus meningitis?
What drug is preferred for the
treatment of invasive
aspergillosis?
Which drug is an alternative
for the initial treatment
of invasive aspergillosis
in a patient with optic
neuritis or peripheral neuropathy?
Now think which drug we
want to avoid in patients
with optic neuritis or
peripheral neuropathy, and
what drug can we give instead.
What drugs are used
to step down for
mucomycosis? Which oral
drug is first line for
vulvovaginal candidiasis?
What adverse effects can occur
with all of the
azo antifungals?
Which azo antifungal
should be avoided in
patients with a history
of heart failure?
Which azo antifungal
is associated with
optic neuritis and
other ocular toxicities?
Which azole antifungal
is associated
with peripheral neuropathy?
Which azole antifungal
is most likely
to interfere with
steroidogenesis?
What is the major
mechanism of drug
interactions with
azole antifungals?
One of the azole antifungals
is cleared renally
and excreted unchanged
in urine. Which one?
What do we need to think about
in terms of dosing
of this drug?
2-triazole antifungals
are formulated with
cyclodextrin to solubilize
hydrophobic drugs for
intravenous administration.
And I put that on the
chart. What toxicity can
occur in patients with
renal insufficiency and
what are the two drugs?
One of the antifungals in
this group does not require
dosage adjustment for patients
with renal insufficiency
or liver impairment.
What is it? And why not?
Now the echinocandins.
These drugs inhibit
this beta-glucan
synthase, which will
weaken the cell wall.
Oh, I just want to go
back to the structure.
You see that this
big old large cyclic
peptide linked to a
long-chain fatty acid.
That's all you need to know.
It's just this big molecule.
Now, this is the chart.
So I put up at the top how
you can just state the
pharmacokinetics of a drug in
a very easy way. IV only,
highly protein bound,
extensive tissue distribution,
but poor CNS ***********.
Slow hepatic non-CYP
metabolism. them excreted in
feces with very little
renal clearance so renal
adjustment is not needed
and it has and the half
-lifes depend on the drug.
Pretty simple isn't it?
Echinocandins are non
-competitive inhibitors of this
beta 1,3 glucan synthase
so it's this one particular
type of beta glucans
and by inhibiting the
synthesis of this glucan,
then that's going to weaken
the cell wall basically
because they're so important
for the structure of the
cell wall, the rigidity.
These drugs have, and
then what happens?
I didn't put it
on here. I should
have put it on here.
So weak cell wall,
weak wall,
water in
osmotic
rupture.
So the cell breaks, lysis.
Activity, narrow spectrum.
Candida, basically
it's fungicidal only
against Candida species.
Several Candida species,
but not all of them.
And it has fungistatic
activity against Aspergillus.
Well that's good news too.
The resistance of Candida is
rare so far, thank goodness.
So it's going to be related to
the gene encoding the target.
And here's the
spectrum of action of
the different ones. I
put only caspafungin
with a star on it.
It's good enough.
It really represents
the whole group.
Caspifungin is used for
all of these purposes.
Risk benefit in patients
who are pregnant, but
these drugs are used
for serious infections.
Well tolerated.
Some phlebitis can
occur at the injection
site. Histamine
-related effects.
Hepatic impairment possible.
Cardiotoxicity, but
this is reported
at low rates.
Drug interactions.
Well, it doesn't, it's
really got low potential
for drug interactions,
but there's a couple
of particular ones and
the mechanism isn't
even known. So I'm just
going to show you this
caspofungan one with
cyclosporine. They can increase
each other's levels and
that can cause toxicity of
each. And cyclosporine, in
particular, is associated
with a number of toxicities
and has a narrow window.
So, to acknowledge what
is the fungal cell target
of the echinocandins,
what is the spectrum, what
is the clinical importance,
what is the effect
of drug interactions and
recommendations for the
use of glucan synthase
inhibitors in pregnancy.
Shifting gears now, we'll
talk about drugs that
are used systemically for
mucocutaneous infections,
griziofulvin and
terbenifene only.
So terbenifene, I mentioned,
blocks this early
precursor step.
Griziofulvin acts
as an antimitotic.
so i put them together so
you can compare they're
basically they're used
basically for the same
purpose griziofolvin is
an old old drug it's been
around a long time has
poor oral absorption low
bioavailability and this
is mainly because of the
absorption and so there are
different formulations that
have been developed to
improve absorption and
therefore improve bioavailability.
This ultra micronized
formulation has the best
bioavailability and also
taking it with fatty foods
improves bioavailability.
Now I've bolded
deposits in carrot and
precursor cells of
skin, hair, and nails,
because that's the
site, that's how,
that's the important
thing to remember about
its distribution in
terms of its action.
And it also concentrates
in lots of other tissues.
Extensive hepatic metabolism,
it's excreted in the urine
mostly as metabolites, and
of course it goes through
the gut, whatever is not
absorbed, and it's got this
variable half-life. Now
looking at turbinafine,
it's well absorbed from the
GI tract, but it has marked
hepatic first-pass effect,
but the bioavailability is
adequate because the drug
company has figured out
the dose that's necessary.
Highly, highly plasma
protein bound. It
accumulates in skin,
nails, and fat. Well,
that's good. That's
where we need it.
Hepatic metabolism
via several CYPs.
And we get a steady state
half-life, that means
with several doses, that's
really, really long.
So, hepatic metabolism,
not recommended for
patients with marked renal
or hepatic impairment.
Mechanism. First,
griziofolvin, it's fungistatic.
It binds to the keratin
in keratin precursor
cells. Now, this drug
keratin complex is taken up
by the dermatophyte as
the hair, skin, and nails
are replaced. So we have
this growth process that's
part of the reason for
the long-time therapy.
Once it's taken up,
griziofulvin binds to the
fungal tubulin, interferes
with microtubule
function, and inhibits
mitosis at the metaphase.
So what is it used for?
The tinea infections,
dermatophytosis. skin,
scalp, hair, nails,
long up to 18 months
duration, depending on
the extent of the
infection and location.
And turbinifine is
largely replaced
griziofulvin for nail ******.
Now, turbinivine is
fungicidal. It inhibits
squalene epoxidase,
prevents ergosterol
synthesis, we'll
go down this path,
and ergosterol depletion
destabilizes the membrane.
And on the other side,
it causes accumulation
of squalene, that's the
precursor in front of the
blocked enzyme, that
accumulates and causes membrane
dysfunction, osmotic stress,
and impaired function,
and we get fungal cell
death. What do we use
it for? Tinea and candida
infections. Drug of
choice for onychomycosis.
It is more effective than
griziofolvin and
itraconazole for nail ******.
Treatment is three months,
which is much shorter than
we saw with griziofolvin.
Still lengthy, though.
Dermatophytosis,
topical. Cutaneous
candidiasis,
topical. Topical use.
Adverse effects,
looking at grizziofolvin
first. It's pretty
tolerable, by and large. It
can cause some headache
and upset stomach,
upset gastrointestinal tract.
Photosensitivity with
this drug and rash.
Hypersensitivity reactions,
it can be quite systemic.
CYP
inducers can, it's a
CY, let me restate.
It's a CYP inducer
that can decrease
contraceptive levels,
leading to contraceptive
failure. I'm going to have
to remember our war friend.
It seems like
everything interacts
with it one way or another.
Contraindicated in
pregnancy it has shown
to be teratogenic.
Hepatic failure,
porphyria, we don't
use it for that either.
Trebinifene, generally
well tolerated, some
GI effects, headache,
can cause a rash,
taste and smell disturbances,
which people can
find really annoying,
but it's not dangerous.
And it can cause
hepatotoxicity, neutropenia,
hypersensitivity, reaction,
severe rash. These are rare,
but they do occur. They
can occur in some patients.
Drug interactions, well, it's
a strong inhibitor of CYP2D6.
So drug interactions in
relation to that enzyme
occur. And pregnancy, the
information is limited. So
it's better to just wait
to treat these infections.
and I've given
you a compare and
contrast grizzio
fulvin table here
I recommend that
you try and fill
this in by yourself
pause the computer
and these are the
and topical antifungal
therapy I'm not going to talk
much about it I do want
to mention ketoconazole,
clotrimazole, nystatin and
terbinifine We've talked
about ketoconazole. We've
talked about terbenifene.
Nystatin is a
polyene. So what does
that say? It's like
amphotericin B.
It is not used
systemically because it is
really toxic, including
nephrotoxicity.
Clotrimazole is just
another azole. And
terbenifene, as I
said, we talked about.
So that's why I have
STARS on these four.
And looking at the chart,
I'm only highlighting
the ones that we have
stars on. You might be
interested in the others,
so I put them on here.
Nystatin, Candida only,
and only topically.
Azoles, various
fungal infections.
Turbinifene,
Dermatophytes, and this
thing called Malassezia
Furfora, just
like the azoles do
Malassezia Furfora.
And therapeutic
uses, according to
the infection that
needs treatment,
so oral candidiasis. This
is Nystatin, it's called a
swish and swallow. It's
an oral. It's put into the
mouth, and the patient is
encouraged to swish it, swish
it around, and either swallow
it or spit it out. Oh,
somehow this got left off.
In a baby, it can just
be painted around in
the mouth. Now, remember,
nyestatin, just like
amphotericin B, is not
going to be absorbed.
So swallowing it
is not going to
produce any systemic
levels at all.
Vulval vaginal
candidiasis, externally,
clotrimazole and
all those others.
Nystatin vaginal
tablets are no longer
available by somebody
who manufactures them.
They have to be prepared
in the pharmacy.
And then we have all
these other things.
So this is a picture
of nystatin oral
suspension that's a swish
and swallow as the doses
in this cup are for
babies, for children,
that can be put into
this dosing dropper.
And clotrimazole, this is
a troche, it's probably
the size of a quarter,
and it's put in the
mouth and allowed to
dissolve there. so this is a
picture of candida albicans
in a baby and summary
I put everything here
in bullets and picture
and check your knowledge
answers and that That
concludes the video on
the antifungal therapies.